JEFF SISSON: Hi.
My name's Jeff Sisson, and I
work at "The New York Times"
as part of a team that builds
the tools the newsroom uses
to publish our journalism.
I hope to describe
how our team uses
open source technologies
and Firestore to create
a completely unique rich
text editor for "The New York
Times."
But first, I want to
describe a radical position
I've come to believe as
a byproduct of our work
on tools for the newsroom.
Hear me out.
Everyone deserves their own
collaborative rich text editor.
So let me explain
what I mean here.
Rich text editors,
like Google Docs,
have made what you see is
what you get style editing
a seamless experience.
This actually makes it
harder to appreciate
some of the complexity that
underlies a pleasant rich text
editor.
Most people just
want it to work.
They want to work
in an editor that
produces HTML-like
documents, which
may include bold, italics,
strikethrough, other emphasis.
And they want to compose using
paragraph, lists, possibly even
tables or images or other
more complex layouts.
Even when just
editing plain text,
there are lots of subtleties
that editors like Google Docs
or Word handle for you.
There's live-as-you-type
text suggestions for grammar
or spelling errors or the
ability for others to comment
on the document or tracking
the changes that you've made
to a document over time.
And it's now even
a common assumption
that if you're editing a rich
text document in a browser,
it must be networked,
meaning anyone
can view the changes
as you're making them
and contribute their
own changes live.
So all of this is
obviously a lot.
It's reasonable to
wonder why anyone
would want to create their
own rich text editor that
does all of these things
rather than relying
on one of the many capable
text editors that exist,
like Google Docs or Word or even
tools like Medium or WordPress.
A little bit more detail on our
work at "The New York Times"
where the tools that we
maintain for editors, producers,
and reporters facilitate
publishing articles
and our coverage of the news.
So "The New York Times"
has a huge newsroom.
At any time of day,
someone is working
to report on world
events in articles
that are often published while
that news is still happening.
We've had a number of
different CMS's over the years.
And when we set out to
build a new article editor,
we knew that we wanted it
to be collaborative first.
Photo editors should be
able to place photos,
while other editors
are polishing a draft
of the text ready to publish.
And, yet, other
editors may be readying
new quotes or new information
for later publishing.
And all of this
needs to be happening
for users that are located in
bureaus around the globe split
amongst many
different time zones.
Enter Oak.
So what is Oak?
Oak is the name of
the rich text editor
we built that
powers every article
published by "The
New York Times."
What are we looking
at in this screenshot?
In the white canvas
in the center,
you can see that the basic
skeleton of an empty "New York
Times" article exists.
You have a headline, a summary,
some bylines, and a timestamp.
Below that, we have
placeholder texts
that commands you to
begin writing where
the innards of the article go.
So things like paragraphs,
images, videos,
interactive graphics,
div text, scrolling text,
and image combinations,
contributor bylines and much,
much more.
This is the basic canvas
for Oak's rich text blocks.
And to the left of that canvas,
there are extra textual tools,
like Spell Check, and validation
for "New York Times'" specific
writing rules, and a
space for writing drafts.
All of these things
together are workflow tools
that are specifically tuned
to how "The New York Times"
newsroom works.
And very few of
these features exist
in other off-the-rack
rich text editors.
So why did we build
Oak from scratch
rather than building
something on top
of a different
proprietary editor?
"The New York Times" has a
specific editorial process
that is very unique to itself.
We use a style
guide that governs
how articles are written.
There are rules for how
obituary headlines are written--
rules for the use of courtesy
titles such as Mr. and Ms.
And rules for the use of
date lines, like WASHINGTON,
in all caps at the
top of an article
to indicate that a reporter
was actually working
from a specific location.
These editorial nuances are
part of what contributes
to "The Times's" unique voice.
And building our
own editor allowed
us to incorporate these rules
into how the editor works
so that the newsroom can
see feedback for an article
as it's being
written and edited.
Before it's published,
reporters may
contribute a first
draft of an article,
then hand off to
a first editor who
may work with the second
editor or copy editor.
Some highly sensitive
articles are even
edited with a privacy mode so
that only parts of the newsroom
that are working on them
can see the articles prior
to publication.
All of these rules for around
who can access the story
and edit it at different parts
of an article's editorial
lifecycle were only able
to be built into Oak
because we were building
an editor from scratch.
And our editor also aims for
what you see is what you mean,
fidelity.
And what does that mean?
So when editors are working
in the Oak article editor,
all of the styles for headlines,
paragraphs, and other elements
that you see as a reader
are also shown to them,
meaning that the newsroom has
instant feedback on exactly
how their story will
look when it's published.
Many rich text editors
are focused primarily
on the editing.
And so this ability to sort of
see the shape of the article
as it's being written has helped
to change the kinds of articles
that we publish.
All of these
features together are
difficult to achieve in
off-the-rack rich text
editors, which is part
of why most of Oak
was built from scratch to
accommodate our newsroom's
needs.
We want our reporters,
editors, and producers
to focus on
contributing journalism
and let the rich
text editor itself
do much of the heavy lifting
around editorial workflow
and document production.
But we didn't attempt to
build our writer alone.
The main technical
component that
allows "The New York
Times" and, of course, you
if you want to create the
rich text editor of our dreams
is called ProseMirror.
It's a set of open source
JavaScript libraries developed
by [? Maryne ?] [? Haverbeck ?]
that do the hard parts of rich
text editing in web browsers.
The browser technology that
most rich text editors rely on
is something called
content editable.
And as a software
spec, it's actually
very messy and inconsistent.
How input events, like pastes,
key presses, and selections
are interpreted vary wildly
between different browsers.
And there are many long-standing
bugs and gotchas even
on modern browsers
like Google Chrome.
ProseMirror
abstracts around many
of these inconsistencies,
which allows
developers to work with
straightforward primitives.
You have a documents
that's represented
by a node, a selection that
uses a selection class.
And changes to a
document are represented
by transforms and transactions.
ProseMirror also handles
painting some of these updates
to a rich text
document into the DOM.
When a document changes,
whether that document is changed
by text that you've
typed into it
or via a remote
collaborating peer,
ProseMirror will make sure
the DOM reflects the latest
state of the document.
In ProseMirror, everything
is a node, even the top level
document.
Each top level document node
contains one or more children,
each of which may contain
their own children
and have attributes.
This document here on screen
represents a very simple
paragraph with the text Hello
world bolded and italicized.
But documents, of course,
can be much more complex.
So every article in "The
New York Times" publishes
contains many types
of different nodes.
And the purpose
of the Oak editor
is to allow editors
in the newsroom
the flexibility to produce
new combinations of nodes that
may share some of the
same node patterns
with other articles that may
use different types of nodes
or different orders
of nodes to emphasize
a particular structure of
a story within an article.
Here, you can see
what our readers
would see for an article
that was created in Oak
and appears on our website
about pollution in China.
And here's that same article
as it appears in the Oak editor
along with a view of the
node data structure that
underlies the article.
All of the rules for what
types of document can contain
and their order
live in something
called a schema definition
that ProseMirror understands
and is able to enforce as you
make changes to the document.
So whenever I'm reading a
"New York Times" article,
I often think about it and
its underlying node structure
and schema with a sort
of X-ray view in my head.
This article about curbing
pollution starts with a header.
And the header contains
itself headline, summary,
a leading media note,
and a byline node.
And the header is
followed by a paragraph
that contains text
itself contains
a link, and so on and so forth.
So ProseMirror schema
allows you to impose
really far-fetched constraints
on your document shape.
It has its own language which
is a subset of RegEx that
can mandate complex
rules of adjacency
for different types of nodes
or constrain how many nodes
of a specific type can be
added in a specific position
or in a row.
This fine-grained
control over what
is valid for a
rich text document
unlocks many fascinating
opportunities
for creating rich text
editors with experiences
that are tuned to different
kinds of documents
that they were built for.
So just to take
some examples, you
might have a Haiku editor that
has live feedback as you're
typing about the number
of syllables per line
and constrains the
lines as you type them.
Or an Oulipo editor
where two people
are working on the same
document at the same time
but only see a shared
strand of text between them
so they compose stories as
part of one holistic whole.
Or maybe you'd have a
highly structured FAQ editor
that offers suggestions
about the types of headings
as you type them.
Or an email editor that
intersperses emoji or color
as you're writing them.
With ProseMirror,
the different kinds
of schemas that you can produce
are really unlimited which
is extremely powerful.
With a schema in place
for your document,
it's time to start editing.
Every change to a
document, whether it's
typing text into a paragraph,
dragging or dropping an image,
or italicizing existing text
produces a data structure
in ProseMirror
that's called a step.
The basic recipe for how you
go from one document state
to the next document state
is by adding a step to it.
Steps are created from
an existing document
and referred to an
indexing system,
whereby, each letter or
leaf node within a document
can be addressed with a number.
So in our example, Hello
world doc, the H in Hello
is at index two.
And similarly, the d in
world starts at index 12.
So if I was to type
in exclamation point
into a ProseMirror
managed editor
with this document in
it, the exclamation point
would be represented as
a replace step, which
is a specific class of step
at position 12 containing
a string which contains
the exclamation point.
ProseMirror's
collaborative plugin
tracks the local
state of the document
using a monotonic counter
that starts at zero.
So if you have an
empty document,
you have a document with
a step counter of zero.
For each step produced
in the local document,
the counter increments by one.
Once the step is created,
the ProseMirror collaborative
plugin requires you
to implement what's
called an authority server
in order for that step
to be synced remotely.
The authority
server's job is either
to accept or reject incoming
steps from multiple clients
according to whether those
clients are attempting
to insert steps in
or out of order.
Clients whose steps
are acknowledged
by the authority's server
continue on their merry way.
Clients whose steps are rejected
because their steps were
submitted out of order and don't
reflect their other peers steps
need to perform an
operation that basically
operates like a git rebase.
The ProseMirror
collaborative plugin
will take into account any steps
that the local client hasn't
yet fetched and change the steps
to reflect those other peers
as steps.
Once this rebase
operation is complete,
the client can attempt to
resend their steps back
to the authority server.
So while ProseMirror's
collaborative editing
architecture requires a central
authority server in order
to order incoming steps
from all connected clients,
it actually only provides
a reference implementation,
which means you're on
the hook to provide
your own implementation.
This reference implementation
is only persisted in memory
and can't really scale.
And so when we set out to build
collaborative editing in Oak,
we knew we needed to
build an authority server.
We evaluated several
different databases
and backend architectures to
support collaborative editing.
But ultimately we
settled on Firestore.
Part of Firestore's
appeal is that in addition
to providing traditional
database functionality,
so as it reads and
writes, it also
comes with a client-compatible
event bus built in.
For Oak, which is a
browser-based application,
this means that we're
able to read and write
changes from the database
directly in the browser.
Oak uses redux and redux-saga
to manage its local state.
And because Firestore
is an event bus as well,
we can treat Firestore as
if it was just another local
to the browser event sync.
Steps arrived from Firestore
and wrapped in redux actions
that mutate the local state.
This vastly simplified
the architecture
we needed to build our editor.
We didn't need to build out
a CRUD API, an event bus.
And all the client-sided
[? after ?] code,
you need to integrate
with the custom back end.
In the Oak editor, each
time a ProseMirror instance
produces a new step, we
serialize that step's data
to JSON and attempt
to write that step
to Firestore using the
latest known step ID plus 1
as the Firestore document key.
For an empty document
starting at step ID 0,
we would attempt to
write our first step
with a Firestore key of one.
And for the second
step, we would
attempt to write with a
Firestore key of two and so on.
If a Firestore document exists
with the next most step ID key,
we end the transaction.
This signals to our
client code that we
need to rebase our local steps
to reflect steps we haven't yet
fetched from Firestore
before attempting to resend
our local steps again.
But if the insert succeeds,
our Firestore listener
will see the steps
as they're inserted.
And we will locally use
this to confirm them
so that subsequent steps
use the new document state
and step ID as the
starting point.
When reading steps,
whether you're
confirming a step you
yourself inserted or receiving
a step from another
collaborator,
the implementation looks
exactly the same-- a Firestore
collection listener.
When the steps
collection is updated,
we fetch any steps greater than
the last step ID and apply them
to the local state
of the document.
Because the listener
executes whether or not
the steps you are attempting
to insert have been successful,
rebasing other client steps are
handled using the same listener
as well.
The Firestore listener acts like
an event stream for any step
that's been confirmed
remotely by Firestore,
whether those steps are
your own or someone else's.
And here, I have a
demo of that Oak editor
that's been modified to sort
of show this process in action.
This is a simplified version
of the Oak article editor.
Normally, Firestore's APIs
are nearly instantaneous.
So I've changed it so
that calls to Firestore
are artificially slower than
they would be in real life
to make it easier to
see what's going on.
I've also added this
text at the top here
that illustrates communication
with Firestore under the hood.
And I've hidden other
parts of the app as well--
set up two tabs-- one
on the left and one
on the right-- that are
connected to the same Oak
article that was just created,
meaning the step counter here
starts at zero.
When I type the word hello in
the headline in the left tab,
a redux saga detects
that there are
steps that haven't
been sent and attempts
to send them with a
Firestore transaction--
one for each letter.
Once the Firestore
transaction completes,
the Firestore collection
listener in the right tab
detects the latest steps and
applies them to the document,
bringing the steps collection
up to five steps stored.
Because this editor has been
artificially slowed down,
we can actually
simulate the case
where both tabs attempt
to execute a Firestore
transaction at the same time.
I'll type the word
world in the left tab
and hi in the right tab.
The left will win, which
causes the right tab
to detect a conflict
and rebase its steps.
After that, it
re-attempts a transaction
inserting its steps,
bringing both tabs up
to sync with each other.
Oak articles, of course, are
not just limited to text.
Because every change is a
step, even pasting something
like a link to an
embedded tweet is
modeled as a step
that will be sent to
and stored in Firestore
in sync with both tabs.
So ProseMirror itself
doesn't mandate
how collaborative
editing is implemented.
And you're free to
choose whichever
backend suits your needs.
Firestore was a good fit
for "The New York Times"
because we needed to build a
collaborative editor really
quickly without worrying
too much about how
the backend would scale.
While our daily number of
articles and production
is relatively modest, the true
scale for our collaborative app
is determined by the rate at
which most people can type,
which can add up quickly.
Choosing Firestore allowed
us to not worry about
whether or not
our database would
handle our anticipated load.
I think Firestore is also a
good fit for anyone building
collaborative editing
that's part of a broader
client-side heavy browser app.
It's really freeing to think of
Firestore as just another event
source within your
browser-based app
where mutations
to your app state
may come from remote
changes or local changes.
And you can focus
your client code
on what those mutations
are doing rather
than how they're produced.
Finally, Firestore
allowed us to simplify
our overall architecture.
We didn't need to
build out a CRED API
or worry about backend
race conditions.
We were mostly able to focus
on our apps business logic.
I hope everyone is sufficiently
enthralled and inspired
to build a million tiny,
beautiful, collaborative rich
text editors for
whatever purposes
shoot your [? windsor ?] fancy.
I want to give a shout out to
the Oak and publishing teams
at "The New York Times."
Have to say that the project of
building a collaborative editor
was truly a multi-year
collaborative
effort in its own right.
And I'm proud of the work
we all jammed on together.
Thank you and go build the rich
text editor of your dreams.